porque los hombres y mujeres
buscan crecer con locura
porque es ser más importante que tu
compañero de al lado
o competir con tu compañero de trabajo
compañero de escuela
es algo que haces con vehemencia
porque es importante
los likes
en nuestras redes sociales
mi primera gran locura llegó en el año
de 1990 99
en la ciudad de poza rica veracruz
poza rica veracruz es una ciudad
parecida a villahermosa tabasco depende
el 98 por ciento de la industria
petrolera
mi padre no construyó su industria su
empresa bajo el sector petrolero
mis hermanos y yo teníamos solo dos
opciones o éramos petroleros
o nos dedicábamos al negocio de mi papá
pero yo estaba loco
abrimos la primera agencia de marketing
en una ciudad que no conocía nada de
mercadotecnia
recuerdo cuando busque a los primeros
profesionistas para abrir la agencia
en una ciudad donde las universidades ni
siquiera tenían la carrera o la
especialidad de mercadotecnia
donde hacer mercadotecnia era hacer
serigrafía volantes camisas
éramos esos locos que andábamos hablando
de marketing petrolero
crecer
es algo inevitable que tenemos instalado
en nuestra cabeza ni siquiera es un
atributo humano crecer lo necesitan las
plantas los seres humanos
las empresas las marcas las
civilizaciones las galaxias
si no me creen
entonces porque fuimos al everest a
pesar de que podría ser un peligro
inminente a conquistarlo
porque un ser humano en una balsa cruzó
el pacífico
porque fuimos a la luna
porque buscamos ser líderes en el lugar
en donde estamos es por eso que vengo a
platicarles sobre los tres puntos claves
para ser un líder en su industria con
una pequeña ruta o metodología que sus
servidores su equipo llaman del punto a
al punto b déjenme les muestro el punto
bueno les voy a enseñar el mío realmente
mi punto a inicia con 62 kilos de más
me acuerdo perfectamente
cuando un amigo bueno es un empresario
que hoy es mi amigo juan
no sé de ese primer gran contrato nos
fuimos a comer unos tacos a una taquería
de poza rica muy popular
y después de esa gran taquilla me dijo
oye usted es muy bueno estamos
contratando pero no puede ser posible
y si es tan bueno y no puedas bajar de
peso
me mató
porque el punto y la razón por la cual
tomó el ejemplo de perder peso
es porque todo empieza venciéndose a uno
mismo y perder peso no se puede simular
tú puedes simular en tus redes sociales
la vida que llevas pero no puedes
simular perder 20 kilos en un año eso
definitivamente lo van a lo vamos a
notar
es más te puedes dedicar el proceso
de bajar de peso pero si no sabes
vencerte a ti mismo vas a regresar al
mismo punto
mi segunda gran locura
llegó cuando tuve en mis manos el
ranking de las mejores agencias de
publicidad de mexico
le dije al equipo si a ese que no sabía
nada de mercadotecnia vamos a entrar al
ranking de mejores agencias de
publicidad es un ranking que califica a
1.200 agencias y después de un puntaje
todas aquellas que rankean quedan dentro
del ranking y a partir de su puntaje
empieza la número uno hasta dependiendo
del año 260 226 100 son las que
arranquen
y recuerdo que ismael el primer
diseñador web que teníamos en una ciudad
costarricense petrolera que no vendía
con páginas web me dijo nos vamos a ir a
la ciudad de méxico rico
dije yo va a por qué
entonces que mira
agencia tal ubicación ciudad de mexico
agencia tal ubicación
ciudad de mexico del 1 al 120 de ciudad
de méxico de ahí algunas de monterrey
alguna de guadalajara y les dije no
lo vamos a hacer desde poza rica
veracruz vamos a arrancar vamos a ir por
esas marcas
cinco años después
conocimos el gusto de ver en la posición
y 72 por tres por tres años seguidos
lo siguiente dígitos de 'marketing' poza
rica veracruz
y esto es por qué
todos los grandes hombres de éxito
han demostrado que además de vencerse de
vencerse uno mismo con disciplina y
constancia identifican y entienden su
porqué
para esto déjenme parafrasear la
historia
de simón cine
contando la historia de los hermanos
wright y su competidor samuel y por
langley
en los años 20
construir o intentar construir
y transporte
tripulado iron propulsado era la onda es
como hoy querer ser influencer todos lo
estaban intentando
samuel peter langley
yo tenía todo tenía la fórmula que
muchos de nosotros consideramos que es
de éxito
las secretarías de defensa de los eeuu
le había dado un contrato de 50 mil
dólares tenía lana
era egresado de harvard y además en
harvard había fundado el taller
smithsoniano
tenía las mejores relaciones públicas
conocía a todos los políticos y grandes
hombres exitosos de su época
era el momento de mercado justo para él
uno de los medios más importantes el
'new york times' lo seguía a todos lados
le daba total cobertura
y para hacer esta labor contrató a los
mejores expertos que el dinero pudo
comprar
a unos cientos kilómetros de ahí en
provincia
estaban los hermanos wright
nadie del equipo de los hermanos wright
ni siquiera ellos tenían educación
universitaria
pagaban su proyecto su idea
con las ganancias de su tienda de
bicicleta
cuentan que cuando salían a hacer sus
prácticas llevaban hasta cinco piezas de
repuesto antes de regresar esa tarde
después de haber intentado echar a andar
su máquina
el 13 de diciembre de 1903 tomaron el
vuelo
nadie los vio nadie estuvo ahí para
verlos no subieron ninguna foto redes
sociales nos centramos después
esto porque tenían un porque creen en
algo tenían un propósito sabían que si
lograban construir el primer avión
cambiarán la forma en que todos los
seres humanos nos transportamos
dejaban sangre sudor y lágrimas
por su parte samuel paper langley no lo
recordamos para nada
a él lo movía la lana lo movía él quiere
ser el primero el prestigio
tanto así
que cuando supo que los hermanos wright
tomaron el vuelo con todos sus recursos
no fue para buscarlos y decirles
muchachos vamos a mejorar la tecnología
juntos el simple y sencillamente
desistió
y tercera gran locura
fue cuando encontré el ranking de los
100 líderes del sector energético
un ranking en que sólo los grandes
influyentes del país
logran participar después de más de 40
años
por qué
queríamos poner
a las empresas mexicanas jugando las al
nivel de las empresas internacionales
que llegaban a méxico participar en la
expropiación de nuestro petróleo
y aquí pulso servidor
y formamos parte de los 100 líderes del
sector energía mexicano
y aquí después de haber mostrado el
punto a
el punto b es
tengan un plan y si su plan lo buscan en
google o lo redactan en una servilleta
no hay ninguna otra fórmula más que
salir a hacerlo
y salgan a hacer sus planes
de lo que sueñan
de los que los motiva dónde está su
porqué
salgan a hacerlos
aunque su competidor tenga un mayor
presupuesto
aunque les queden 20 días para organizar
este gran evento
joaquín villahermosa tabasco saben donde
desarrollamos la expongas méxico hace
apenas un año
nos hicieron
para que un evento más y ya hay 36 en el
sector energía hay 4 al mes no hay
presupuesto la peor crisis
esperábamos 2000 personas
llegaron 6000
días después
en todo una reportera del sector consejo
le darías a los chavos que hoy están
viviendo los cambios en el sector que se
enfrentarán las competencias
internacionales
si tienes un plan
hazlo
sigo estando loco saben
lo sé porque cada vez que veo junto con
nuestro equipo de trabajo un reto así de
grande como el de cada uno que les hemos
platicado
me hago la pregunta
es posible bajar estrellas a pedradas te
puedo ver a ti grande agarrar piedras y
bajarte
piedras en todos lados
les doy la respuesta
si es posible bajar estrellas a pedradas
aunque las leyes naturales y físicas
digan lo contrario
grábense lo si tienen un plan aunque tus
padres tu mejor amigo tu pareja te diga
que no tu sal y hazlo gracias
[Aplausos]